The type of woman
that will date a man that is in conflict with the mother of his child
is not gonna be open to hearing what the fuck you have to say.
There is no point in reaching out to her.
If you reach out to her,
the only thing you're going to do
is confirm to her the lies that he's already told her.
Because don't you even think
their first date was not just a full on trauma bond session,
just venting.
And she's telling her all the ways these men have hurt her
and all her insecurities,
basically giving him an entire fucking roadmap
on how he could fucking abuse and manipulate her.
He's eating it up
and telling her all the fucking crazy things that you did
that line up with what her ex did.
So now they're like,
oh, my god, nobody fucking gets me like you got me.
It's like Anna and Hans in the fucking car.
Love is an open door.
Love bombing the fuck out of each other and they're hooked.
So you reach out to her and now she's trying to break up our love.
Girls, don't even do it.
It's not worth it.
Let them have each other because they are each other's karma.
They are each other's karma.
Don't even bother.